una tierra antigua escondida en una zona
remota de los himalayas en un valle a
3800 metros por encima del nivel del mar
se encuentra el antiguo reino de lo que
se volvió parte de nepal a finales del
siglo 18
pero la monarquía solo se abolió en 2008
este asentamiento medieval era la
capital un muro de tierra de 6 metros de
altura con torres cuadradas rodea casas
templos y el palacio
esta orden a la ordenada este es el muro
que rodea el pueblo
es una fortaleza
también tenemos torres de vigilancia
allá hay 14 en total
este sistema de defensa se desarrolló
para protegernos de los enemigos que
venían del norte y del sur la ciudad
amurallada es un patrimonio milenario de
la humanidad considerado único por la
unesco
antiguamente solía ser parte de una
concurrida ruta comercial entre nepal y
el tíbet hasta la micción del tíbet en
1950 esta es mi casa
el apogeo de este lugar fue hace siglos
y las comodidades modernas aún no han
llegado a estas tierras remotas
ya está lista las vacas a pesar del frío
extremo las casas solo tienen
electricidad unas horas al día no hay
bosques alrededor así que no hay madera
para quemar en vez de eso los locales
queman boñigas seca de vaca lo más duro
es cuando nieva mucho la nieve cubre
toda la casa y es difícil deshacerse de
ella para poder sacar nuestro ganado y
llevarlo a tomar agua el río
el asentamiento está rodeado por las
montañas más altas de los himalayas la
tierra de los alrededores de la manzana
es árida la cosecha de frutas y verduras
sólo es posible un mes al año el resto
del tiempo la comunidad depende de sus
rebaños para la comida
estos jacques son el animal más
importante de los himalayas
[Música]
los voy a dejar al otro lado de la
montaña vendré a recogerlos esta noche
este pastor es dueño de un rebaño de dos
docenas de yaks que deambulan libremente
por la montaña
en verano me gusta subir todavía más
ahora nos quedaremos aquí porque es
donde hay pasto es difícil criar jacques
los animales salvajes suelen atacar el
rebaño tengo que quedarme despierto toda
la noche para protegerlos de los lobos y
de los leopardos de las nieves
la región de mustang estuvo aislada del
mundo hasta 1992 cuando los turistas
obtuvieron un permiso para visitar el
lugar pero no es un viaje sencillo para
proteger la región del turismo masivo
los visitantes deben solicitar un
permiso que cuesta alrededor de 500
dólares
a estos locales les gustaría que las
restricciones se redujeran
sería bueno que el precio de las
licencias bajara entre más turistas
tengamos más podrá desarrollarse el
pueblo fíjense qué pasa con los turistas
que no pueden pagar sería bueno bajar
los precios para ellos
fundado por un caudillo militar tibetano
en 1380 hoy en día la lejanía de lo
manzana lo convierte en uno de los
últimos bastiones de la cultura
tradicional tibetana
estoy tan contento de vivir aquí mira
este paisaje
la región está llena de miles de
cavernas budistas que los monjes visitan
para rezar una vez al año este monje va
a una cueva a meditar después de una
hora de camino a través de la montaña
finalmente llega a uno de los monumentos
más significativos de la región estas
cuevas se remontan al siglo 12 y están
adornadas con frescos sagrados
aquí esta duda con sus discípulos estos
son monjes jóvenes
para
los monjes solían venir aquí a rezar
porque así no los molestaban otras
personas o animales
pequeño paraíso en lo alto de las
montañas lo manzana es un tesoro
cultural cobijado por un pasado que
forma parte integral de la vida
cotidiana